ANKUR KOTWAL: Hi.
Welcome to this
series on Geocasts,
where you can walk your
way through what you
can do with Google Maps APIs.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
In part one, we saw how you
could delegate your mapping
work to the Google Maps app.
In part two, we saw how
you could go further
by incorporating Google
Maps functionality
right into your app.
And then in part
three, we looked
at integrating Maps, and some
of the smarts behind Maps,
into your apps.
In this video, we'll
go deeper still,
and we'll talk about getting
raw data from Google so you can
orchestrate it in your apps.
Let's start with
the Directions API.
This is a web
service that provides
smart content about
directions and times,
including predictive
travel times.
We can forecast what
traffic conditions
are likely to be based
on historic data.
Now, directions aren't
just for driving.
The web service
provides walking,
biking, and public
transport directions, too.
You can get all this
information in JSON or XML,
parse it, and use it.
The Places API you saw
in an earlier video
also has a web service.
So you can query to
get lots of information
about a particular place.
So here you can see me searching
for Moscone in San Francisco,
and then finding a number of
places that match that name.
And, for example, if I look
for restaurants in Sydney,
I'll get a payload like
this, with great information
about these places.
Now, as people, we don't
think of locations in terms
of latitude and longitude.
We rarely even think of
a location by address.
We like to think of locations by
name, such as, my house, where
I work, my favorite
restaurant by name.
The Places API helps us find
places based on their names.
And once we have that place, we
can get some excellent metadata
about it.
You can use these tools to
provide that user friendliness
to your users.
We also have native Places
API calls for Android and iOS.
And with these, you
can incorporate them
into real world
places into your apps.
Based on the readings about
your device's location,
for example, latitude,
longitude, or Bluetooth
beacons, the Places API
can figure out real places
that you are likely
in as a result.
So instead of being
at a lat/long,
your users can know that they
are at a particular real world
place, like a coffee shop.
It calculates a likelihood
for a particular location
based on a variety
of factors, including
things like opening hours.
I now want to talk
about the Roads API.
And it's used for when you
use your GPS on your phone.
Often, that signal can be
quite noisy, the GPS location.
And with this API, we
can snap the locations
that our phone gives us to
actual roads in the real world.
This can also make for a
really nice user experience.
So these are a few examples
of some of the web services
that are available.
We also provide Libraries
for these web services
for lots of popular languages.
Now, do note that these
Libraries are designed
to be consumed server-side.
They're protected
by API keys, so you
should consider running
this code on your server
and then talking to your
server with your app
rather than having those
Libraries run locally
in your apps on
the mobile device.
So that's it.
I can't wait to
see what you build.
And if you have any questions,
please reach out on Twitter
or Google .
Thanks for watching.
[MUSIC PLAYING]